what is going on guys
welcome to the 12th fundamental
investing with use
programming tutorial video where we left
off we were visiting this quandl.com and
pulling financial
data and now that we have the data we
want to
organize it into an array and then we're
going to use that array
and graph from that array so first step
we need to
create these arrays and then start
ordering things within them so
the first thing we need to do is make
the arrays
so i'm going to call this net income
r for net income array and it'll be
empty for now
then rev array
and then roc array
now the next thing we want to do is
scroll down
and we want to
instead of printing these out here i'm
going to we're going to change up this
array a little bit
so um
so i'm just going to actually delete all
of this
and we'll come over here and now what
we're going to say
is split and i for split net income
it's going to equal net oops net income
dot split by new line
because if you remember uh the output of
this text was
you know line by line so first we want
to split it up by
each new line and then if you recall the
first line
of text was descriptive text so we don't
really want that text
um and the last line was an empty
line so we don't want that line either
so
with that in mind we'll say we'll print
um
net income and now what we're going to
do is use a for loop so we're going to
say 4
each and i for each net income in
split and i and then we're going to use
the first element or the even though
it's not the first element right that's
actually
one means number two and zero means
number one but one
two the negative first
element so this will go all the way to
the negative first element so it will go
all the way
and stop before that blank line
um so now we'll say print each
ni and then what we're going to do is
append it to our
net income array so net income array
with two p's append and we want to
append
um each and i
so now we'll scroll down
and the next thing we want to do is
we're going to say
actually let's print like a little
divider here
and the next thing we want to do is
split
rev so split up revenue line basically
equals
revenue dot split and again we're going
to split by a new line
and then we'll print out a revenue
and now we're going to say for each rev
in split rev and again same parameters
as before for the exact same
reason as before
um print
each rev and then
rev array.append
each rev
and then again we'll print out one of
these little dividers
and down and now it's going to be
split roc equals roc dot split
again by new line then we'll say print
return on capital
and then we'll say
for each roc in split
roc um and again
one to the negative first
element print each roc
and roc array.append
each roc now
uh we've probably got a type of someone
here so it might not work
but let's go ahead and save that run it
see what we got and it turns out we did
not have
any typos wow it's like a first so it
connected
and you can see it's it's still printed
out everything just like we remember it
doing before
um no more empty line either what
and even though we're not seeing it
being printed out everything was
appended
to uh these each each thing was appended
to
its you know specific array so now what
we can do
uh is call that array turn it into a
numpy array
then we can use the date that's already
in date format convert it to
matplotlib m dates format then
we can graph it in date format
then we can put it together in
everything and make an
epic uh investing program so anyways in
the next video we're going to be
discussing uh moving this into a numpy
array
and maybe if we have time in the next
video without running it too long
we'll also uh go ahead and just generate
a graph out of it
so anyway uh as always thanks for
watching thank you for all your support
your subscriptions
and until next time